[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMMET O'NEILL: StoryToys
is a creator and publisher
of children's app content.
We make everything from original
IP to classic fairy tale books,
right all the way through
to licensed content.
GAVIN BARRETT: What we do is
we combine a reading experience
with interactive scenes.
It's a nice combination
of an educational reading
experience with a
slightly gamified
interactive experience.
So they don't so much interrupt
the reading experience
as draw the child in, make them
feel part of the narrative.
EMMET O'NEILL: One of
the biggest challenges
of working in the
children's app space
is that you have two audiences.
First you have the children, but
you also have to sell the app.
We have to try and create
an experience that's
both appealing, but also to the
parent represents good value,
has sound educational
values, effectively something
that the parent can feel good
about letting their child
interact with.
GAVIN BARRETT: Since the launch
of the Family section on Google
Play, our experience
with Android
has been completely transformed.
We saw a huge uplift in
revenues and our downloads, too.
Google Play was now
our number one channel.
It's been nothing but
positive for StoryToys,
and we're delighted
to be involved.
EMMET O'NEILL: The Family
section on the Google Play
Store has really provided a
safe, trusted creative space
for families to
find new content.
Android is fantastic for rapid
iteration and prototyping,
absolutely hands-down the best.
You can beta test on the store.
I think we've got
fantastic opportunities
to do that with a much
wider audience, too.
GAVIN BARRETT: The Play
Store delivers global reach.
As a distribution
channel, it's unrivalled.
Google Play allows you to
customize pricing per market.
That's an extremely
powerful tool.
You can then use the
translation services
on Google Play, an
extremely efficient way
to get all the content in
your app translated quickly.
EMMET O'NEILL: Google Play
has allowed My Very Hungry
Caterpillar to reach some
pretty staggering numbers.
We found that kids playing
with the app, in general,
have engaged with it
between 80 and 120 minutes.
We've found that kids
cumulatively have made more
than a million butterflies.
And they've fed the
Very Hungry Caterpillar
more than a quarter of a billion
pieces of fruit within the app.
GAVIN BARRETT:
We're really excited
about the next few
years for StoryToys,
and particularly focusing on
education and the opportunities
that lie there.